you know that I cheated on you so like
both times I cheated on him it was um a
threesome
oh [ __ ] this one is lost too hi I'm Sav
hey I'm Manny and we're ex-partners yeah
yeah all right let's see
describe our past relationship in three
words
volatile ah exciting messy yeah I agree
with both of y'all toxic there's
something always interesting whenever
there's X's for some reason whenever you
look at body language it's so obvious
which one's into the other one it's so
obvious This Guy's super into her she's
laid back relaxed and this dude's
leaning forward like this it's a man
it's like a physical manifestation of
how they have their relationship set up
my language I don't know about that I'm
so sensitive to that kind of stuff two
messes that make it clean but it's a
mess so what you're thinking about
what was the kinkiest thing we did there
was definitely some rib stuff yeah but I
don't think we got that game
did she just say that she got some there
was some grape juice stuff uh
uh and then she said that's not that
kinky
listen I don't know much about her sex
life but I refuse to visit her dungeon I
think it was failure vanilla because I
remember when we were dating I would be
like you know let's do this and let's do
that and you're like
I mean we did I know a couple times yeah
we did
and I think we both enjoyed that but oh
no I don't I don't think I could no I
mean I'm sorry but you know it's not um
a small amount to take
oh come on
come on you're not even the biggest
thing I've had up there I mean
call me
I'm just saying
remember that body language he's trying
to qualify himself yeah that was pretty
big wasn't I and she's shooting that
[ __ ] down all laid-back lives
listen Tyrone was way better
call him
what okay listen Little India
Tyrone I mean
okay
did I fulfill you sexually
this is
hey homie you gonna need some therapy
and we know somebody to help you Greg
Mato says it's your fault and you need
to up your skills
ego definitely needs some therapy she
not meant to no words but hey I ain't
even mad at her you wanna know why
because he asked the question and he
invited her to do this [ __ ] yeah so you
gotta hold this oh
[Music]
well am I supposed to answer as well
because y'all have a show yeah
he tried to come back
you went from we did some pretty [ __ ]
kinky [ __ ] too yeah yeah whatever no
nobody will leave you hold this out bruh
because she's killing you right now hold
it she's killing you right now did you
ever cheat on me if not did you ever
come close definitely came close a few
times oh what'd you do
that's like you know she doesn't give a
[ __ ] bro she don't care oh nice who is
it this is sexy I think I had her
I could tell the moment they break up
she already had another dude lined up
and she and she was getting her back
blown out yes blown
[ __ ] cat you know that I cheated on
you so like
[Music]
yo
yo
yo
cold blooded cold
blooded hey man she don't zero emotional
care she says I'm a [ __ ] no [ __ ] yes
go ahead and say it I I don't care this
is the type of girl to squirt all over
your bedroom without giving you a
warning [ __ ] up all your furniture
annuals yeah so she'll squirt on your
sofa just for the [ __ ] of it yeah yeah
we went from [ __ ] on your couch [ __ ]
to [ __ ] your couch
nearly hooked up with the people a few
times yeah I was like anyone I know ever
he sounds like he's making it up no I
don't think so oh well that's boring
yeah sorry I'm more of a uh do it where
you can't be seen kind of person yeah I
guess I was a bit more obvious with mine
yeah when you thought you weren't both
times I cheated on him it was um a
threesome and that was the first which
is like doubly defeated I know which is
so when you were getting seen it on she
was taking two dicks at the same time
two of them you know that's different
that is different I know he's different
but it's her different it definitely
hits her different it's hurting places
she didn't know she could be hit but
that's why it's different because [ __ ]
don't like being cheated on we always
say this a [ __ ] walks in the home sees
a dude she was a girl you gotta fight
him he sees two [ __ ] he's like ah
shall come back later
because you're not gonna fight both of
these things you definitely gonna lose
like two [ __ ] in the comments guys in
the comments I'm not saying you should
fight somebody if you catch them cheat
on you no you shouldn't but if you see
two dudes raining your girl all right
these two big ass man ego [ __ ] what
you gonna do
because I'm gonna be honest me
hey man listen I like The Simpsons
I'm in and out
damn imagine two of them you open the
door two of them Cindy how could you
with Tom and Jerry man shut the [ __ ] up
and Liam
what the [ __ ] are you doing man what the
[ __ ] are you doing shut up close the
door both of them
see it like so bad but that was when we
first started dating and then there was
the threesome with the couple that we
both knew and that was a couple days
before we've broken up it's been pretty
relaxed
so sad how does that make you feel man
uh I've had worse
it is
what was difficult about being with me
you hadn't gone to therapy
I think you had a lot of issues that you
hadn't dealt with those were taken out
on me all the time for three whole years
and that was why it was incredibly
difficult as tumultuous as it was I'm
really happy and proud of the person
that I am now and I don't think I could
have been that if we hadn't been
together you weren't the first bad
relationship but you were definitely the
last you know you were the first like
serious relationship I ever had yeah
like a door opening that's what it is if
you know that song by Roddy Rich The Box
you
oh
what's your fondest memory of us
do you remember that French lady when we
were in Budapest we were talking to her
after I get a photo of us we were so in
love like as we can see it in the photo
yeah like we were looking at each other
it's unbelievable the way that she
talked about how she saw us after she
took that photo you could see that like
there was something in her past that she
could see that was in us it was kind of
like a moment of like cementing for me
where like I realized how much I did
she's so like oh no I don't like you man
yeah it's it's yeah you see see the
details about memory
she went yeah oh yeah I remember that
the first she was done this guy wrote a
whole novel and then you went on and
went on and went on and then ugh
when someone don't want you and you're
just professing how much you're in love
with them or were in love with them and
just going on and on it just makes you
even more and more unappealing I feel
bad for the guy I feel bad for him
because but he did it himself so you got
to hold that L Brad I don't feel bad
yeah and and how much you love me and it
just felt very real and one of the first
times I ever felt like
like oh foreign
stop that's what it feels like we were
us I barely remember that night but um
Oh my days
hey my friend
you have been killed and bowed you are a
casualty of War
when you have decided to wage yourself
you are Russia who has decided to go to
Ukraine you have not brought the right
soldiers you have lost now you are
engaging in a draft nobody wishes to
join
ah oh [ __ ] this one is lost
oh [ __ ] she [ __ ] that [ __ ] up
she for after that whole lot that whole
long-ass parade this motherfucker's
gonna be like I remember all that [ __ ]
so calm down you know how you were in
love with me yeah it was good and I
don't remember
let's be depressed that's so cute
so
cute
casually why not yeah it would just be
the question of how do we keep it from
devolving back into some weird quasi
relationship yeah I don't know that's a
no move on you keep on talking dude
that's it I like that I can talk to you
and you know me well enough to give me
responses that both challenge me and
validate me at the same time it's nice
to have someone that I can clearly
communicate with I'm happy to be that
person yeah oh disgusting just gross
just disgusting
do yourself a favor bro move the [ __ ] on
stop talking to her stop thinking about
it don't do this [ __ ] again okay it has
some self-respect bro have some
self-respect
oh rough very hard to watch but we got
through it guys like I said
body language in the first 10 seconds I
already knew this [ __ ] was not gonna go
well
first 10 seconds
you called it that's you
I didn't know it was gonna go that bad
but I knew it wasn't going to go well
for him oh last thing right bro all
right listen fine that's just let his
mouth tight though how do you guys feel
about what you saw do you guys agree or
disagree yeah let us know in the
comments